foreign
Kansas City hi Jason how are you
hey I'm great how are you guys better
than we deserve what's up
I figured hey thanks for taking my call
I have a quick question on a rental and
putting down payment on a rental so my
wife and I are debt free we currently
contribute we Max our 401k and we
currently contribute to our child
support to the child's college fund and
we are excited to buy a second home to
use as a short-term rental and you're
wondering what your current home is paid
for as well
it is not that is the only debt we've
got as our mortgage other than that we
are debt free okay so we are wanting to
know we want to put 20 down it'd be
about a million dollars
um we're currently saved up at about 150
000 so we're 50 short and I'm trying to
Fast Track that so I wanted to know does
it make sense to um stop temporarily
stop contributing to the child's college
and 401K we could pay it off I'm sorry
save about fifty thousand dollars in
about a year
um
short term you got the fever bad for
this it's a good time to buy in a Year
Dave you got the fever bad was it beach
house or what
I don't know if you're gonna do what we
teach or not
um because you got the fever uh but I'll
tell you what I have done and what we
have recommended since I've been on the
air
that when you do a second house even if
it's for income rental property or
partial vacation home you know Resort
rentals what you're dealing with here
um that you pay cash for it after your
home is paid for I have a lake house and
the first purchase I ever made like that
was a lake house and
um it's not the one I'm currently in but
um it was uh it was a big deal to us our
home was paid for we saved up the money
we paid cash for the little it wasn't a
very fancy place but it got us on the
water and we got it you know we had a
place to go on the weekends the kids
grew up skiing down there and then later
on WE tore that house down or got rid of
the house gate donated it and moved it
and built another bigger property on
that same lot and that's where we were
last weekend
but you know luxury properties if you
even if you partially justify them with
um
rental income with Resort rental income
which is heavy in management fees
because it's generally nightly rentals
and it's generally seasonal too uh but
the even if you partially justify it
with that is still at the end of the day
a toy and you pay cash for toys now
again I don't know if I'm gonna talk you
out of this you some to me like the
words you're using your sentence
structure you're pretty far down the
road on this but I would pay off your
home first
and then I would shave up and buy my
rental properties or safe up and buy my
uh
second homes with cash and by the way
that's what I've done I didn't do
otherwise and I didn't do a different
thing and then teach you guys different
because I'm going to get you out of debt
and keep you out of debt
um and so of all the millionaires that
we interviewed 10 000 of them Jason
uh we didn't have one that said you know
I made all my money leveraging into my
vacation Mountain House
after I'd gotten out of debt and almost
got my house paid off I leveraged into a
vacation Mountain House and that that
made all the difference in my finances
on the contrary we asked them what
mistakes they have made and almost
always it was associated with going into
debt to buy a car or to buy something
after they had almost made it and you've
almost made it so I really would ask you
to rethink this but I'll say one more
time from the way you're talking about
this I don't know if we did any good or
not it's hard it's hard to back out once
you're that far in yeah well I was going
to ask you a follow-up on that what's he
really I mean how would someone you've
explained all of the financial piece
what would you coach him with
emotionally if he's going to actually do
what you told him how do you get to that
place when you're already you can see it
taste it smell it
cold shower
there's going to break the fever
take two of these and call me in the
morning it's house fever right it's just
because I do the same thing I get when I
am purchasing even to this day
um when the vast majority of my
purchases today are not they don't move
the needle right but uh in terms of the
emotions of it
um but even that like I get ready to buy
a car I get into it sure and I'm
studying it and you know the the you
know the activator thing you start
seeing them everywhere right oh yeah and
uh I get into it and you just we all do
that yeah we all get and the bigger the
purchase the more complicated the
purchase the bigger the purchase
relative to your situation oh yeah the
more
you the the more you obsess about it
yeah and this in this situation is a
true lifestyle purchase like he can see
a million dollar that is right second
home oh yeah almost totally on debt
right
I mean 20 Down's a joke on that I mean
it's just not even right it's hard to
get to financing at that but the uh uh
still it's just uh that's a lot yeah but
I mean he's he's he's spent a lot of
nights in that cabin in his mind already
that's what I'm saying I would have if
it was me yes sir I get I get all jacked
up about it he's already found a
breakfast place at the bottom of the
hill everything listen
I bought a new Surf Boat a new
Mastercraft Surf Boat I got so much
dialed into that man I was so every
detail on the website every color Choice
Every Little D new I mean you would have
thought I was doing a eight million
dollar transaction right right I'm just
so dadgumed down and stuck my head so
far in it and if you just told me in the
middle of that if my wife would have
said you know I changed my mind I don't
think we should do that
wait wait wait wait wait because you get
you get into it and that's just a normal
human process so I don't know if I know
how to tell you how to back out of it
other than joke about it and just go
it's human nature sometimes you need to
put full stop on a bad idea yeah
um when you're in the middle of it and I
will tell you this
um you know we have Pastor Max on he's
talking about peace
the Peace of the Holy Spirit and
um
there's a scripture that goes with that
from a financial standpoint this says
the blessings of the Lord
have no sorrow added to them
and so if I can look at the situation
and can perceive
sorrow in the future of it
then that usually is telling me that's
not a God thing I'm doing it's a Dave
thing I'm doing and I got the I done
went and got the fever you know that was
it I mean I got the fever you live to
tell about it I got I got suckered in by
my own intellect and I can I can I can
do mental gymnastics and talk myself
into something and all you out there can
too sure we all can we all do it and so
it's a it's an interesting call to not
poke fun at Jason just to instead say
we're all just like you yes for sure and
yet begging you not to do this deal
uh because it's not good for your family
so it's really what could go wrong oh so
much and then you start to deal with
that and that kind of becomes that cold
shower hopefully to go all right wait a
second the most high risk real estate is
being a developer developing a property
in the slots or whatever you're doing
with it the second most high risk real
estate Resort real estate right
and because if you think about it Resort
real estate is luxury and so what
happens is Beach and Mountain Lake
they all go straight up when times are
hot and straight to the bottom when
times are cold this is the first thing
that people dump when they're when
they're struggling that's right and and
they buy it when they're flush
and so when the economy is going to zoom
zoom you know my lake house will double
some years and it'll go in half later on
you know in value as we watch it back
and forth and that happens with Beach
property it happens with you know you
watch the 30A coach down there oh
depending on zoom zoom for a while but I
do remember when there were Towers
sitting empty with wind blowing through
them down there they have to stinking
places on foreclosure and it doesn't
feel like that long ago to me
uh so you know it's just it's it's very
volatile category of Real Estate